how concerned are you about the india
variants
well i i mean there are there's good
reason to be concerned as you've heard
um so there's a high degree of
confidence that this virus is more
transmissible
and a realistic possibility that the
increased transmissibility over the
current so-called kent variant b117
is up to 50 more transmissible and
you've just had a discussion with the
health secretary
you know dissecting those different
points but i mean there are clinic
grounds for concern
but there is substantial uncertainty and
uh that's been the challenge for
policymakers throughout the whole
pandemic which is that they're
always having to make decisions in the
face of incomplete evidence
the job of the scientists is to present
that evidence as clearly as we possibly
can
and matt hancock said that if it is 50
more transmissible
then there'll be problems what would
those problems look like
well i think the problem will be that
the infection will
uh take off and there'll be very large
numbers of infected people
uh particularly amongst those people
that haven't been vaccinated yet
uh people who are only partially
protected because they've had one
vaccination and again as you've heard
in a small potential cases the
vaccination for whatever reasons doesn't
work
um and so uh whilst it is perfectly true
that the vaccines and it's been a
remarkable story and we've got you know
two-thirds of the adult population with
one jab in their arm and half of that
number with two jabs approximately
it does protect you against severe
infection and death
nevertheless that isn't complete and the
challenge essentially is that a small
fraction
of a very large number uh that's the
particular people who are potentially
infected
gives you a lot of people that could be
quite sick
given that do you think it is the right
decision to go ahead with monday's
unlocking well that is the decision that
policymakers have to make it's uh it's
why it's easier to be the scientific
advisor than it is to be the politician
um the answer is that i think that you
are hearing them all saying well please
be cautious
um and uh the addition of fresh air to
the hands facing space i think is
extremely important that is the most
important thing of all at the moment
and the good thing about the time of
year where the weather hasn't been great
is that it is possible to spend much
more time outside
and so fresh and do things outside you
should
and if you're doing things inside then
make sure the windows are open and it's
being properly ventilated
if fresh air is the most important thing
i understand that it's a decision for
politicians it's difficult for
scientists for members of this age but
if fresh air is the most important thing
why are we going ahead with the
expansion
again you've been asking about hancock
that um each of us will have our own
opinions but um i'm not elected you're
not elected so
um i i you know my job is to
help let people know what the science
actually says um
and uh it's job of course of patrick
valance and uh chris whittie to provide
that direct advice to
ministers and um you know it's perfectly
clear from the interview with uh
secretary just now that he's hearing the
evidence and he's having to make
quite tough decisions in the face of
uncertainty
but i think the critical thing at the
moment is to firstly that
vulnerable people who have not been
vaccinated really need to get vaccinated
and that's why it's important that
there's this
these efforts to serve the vaccination
to the people that are eligible
in places like bolton and blackburn and
other parts of the country
so that's really important because if
you haven't had a vaccine
it you really must have one actually
there's no good reasons for not
so that's the important thing but then
it is i think a question of people
making
judgments and you know my personal
judgment is that i will do things
outside as far as possible
um so you're not going to be heading to
indoor pub tables then you're going to
be staying outside
outside i think for the moment yes um
you're talking about the evidence that
scientists are presenting to government
in which they can then make the
decisions
so what does the evidence suggest might
happen after monday's
changes are we likely to see a rise in
infections or hospitalizations so the
control of this infection still depends
on two things it depends on social
distancing because the virus basically
has to transmit by proximity from one
person to another essentially
and the effect is the vaccine the
vaccine program is amazing it's a
tremendous logistic achievement
and it has had a huge impact
but we now have a virus that is
even more able to transmit than its
predecessors so
it becomes a tougher race um and so you
know that is the
that's the critical issue at the moment
if you're looking at and look at the uh
stage minutes that were published
yesterday which were saying that there
is a
realistic possibility that the
individual is 50 more transmissible than
the chem variant
and if that's the case it's likely that
progressing with step 3 alone
which is the changes on monday would
lead to a substantial resurgence of
hospitalizations
similar to or larger than previous peaks
that's quite shocking it feels well i
mean it's a very clear
uh statement and you know there's good
evidence to back up the statement
but it's why it's going to be extremely
important to keep a very very close eye
on the numbers over the next
few weeks and one of the troubles with
this pandemic throughout
is that there is a gap between someone
becoming infected
and them ending up in hospital and then
potentially the terrible outcome of them
dying or being severely uh disabled by
the disease
and so you're always paying catch up in
terms of looking at the numbers
now uh case numbers at the moment
nationally
are uh fortunately uh low there's about
2 000 cases
picked up each day but we do know for
example in bolton the case numbers are
much higher at
just over 200 per hundred percent of the
population
um in bedford they're about hundreds so
um
we've really got to keep an eye on the
numbers so test
trace and isolate is really important
it's critical that people
do get tested and do report if they have
symptoms and isolate themselves and
their families
these are all really important things
but and we are going to learn over the
next two or three weeks what the
impact of the changes is and um
the problem is that the data takes some
while to emerge
um which is why there's you know every
grounds to be very cautious about
the ability to open up in in june but i
mean i think it's fair to say it is a
perilous moment
um we have a variant that shows
you know good evidence of being more
transmissive and possibly significantly
more transmissible
we're going to have to watch the numbers
extremely closely um
and the other thing that we do know is
that the this new variant
from india is actually quite widely
distributed across the country
um so we know about the hotspots but it
is in all four nations uh
there's a fair amount about and it is
increasing in proportion
uh in terms of when the genomes of the
case is looked at
we also know that it's in at least 60
countries around the world it's in
a number of countries across europe it's
the united states
and it's doing what previous variants
have done which is that as
a fitter variant of the virus emerges
it takes over as the dominant strain
around the world
and if you like the relief with this
variant is that the evidence so far
suggests that the existing vaccines do
protect against
the most severe effects of the infection
and death
but we still have a certain amount to
learn we don't know how much the
vaccines protect against
people getting milder infection and
their ability to transmit to others
and that's why this constant vigilance
is absolutely critical
you mentioned the june unlocking of
course matt hancock made it very clear
that that is
under review um do you feel that
normality has
got a little bit further away for us uh
well i
possibly uh but i think that people have
said all along that
you know this is a very uh pesky virus
it's very versatile in its ability to
you know change and evade that's what
viral evolution is all about
and so you know complete normality i
think it's going to take a bit of time
to return
and people have got to be sensibly
cautious i think
sensibly cautious what what would your
advice be then for people from monday
well my advice is that uh you know
just because you can do something
doesn't necessarily mean you should as
far as possible
socialize outside maintain
uh social distancing you know if you're
going to hug
cautiously um how do you hug cautiously
well you don't well without making great
demonstrations
um tight glitches should be avoided